يبدو ان العالم او غالبيه العالم غير راض
عن حرب روسيا على جارتها الغربيه اوكرانيا
وهذا ماضح من بيان قمه مجموعه العشرين
المنعقده في بالي الاندونيسيه هناك في
بالي بدا زعماء اكبر الاقتصادات في العالم
بداوا مستعدين لايصال رساله قويه بشان
اداره الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
المستمره منذ تسعه اشهر والتي حملت دمار
كبيرا وعكرت صفوه الاقتصاد العالمي كرر
قاده مجموعه العشرين في مسوده بيانهم
ادانت الامم المتحده للحرب على اوكرانيا
لكن مع الاعتراف بوجود وجوهات نظر مختلفه
بين اعضاء التكتل الاقتصادي الكبير صيغه
البيان بدقه لمراعات التوترات السائده في
القمه التي تضم روسيا والصين والتحدي الذي
تواجهه الولايات المتحده وحلفائها لعزل
حكومه الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين لماذا
نقول التراث لان بعض الدول تسعى الى تجنب
التورط في الصراع بين القوه الكبرى خصوصا
حلفاء موسكو باكين ونيلهي مسعى واشنطن لم
يعجب موسكو سيرجيو راموس
تاسيس الاعلان المشترك وادانه روسيا
بالانابه عن جميع دول مجموعه العشرين
بالرغم من ان الموضوع خارج جدول اعمال
المجموعه نعم هناك حرب في اوكرانيا الغرب
بدائها وكان يحضر لها منذ سنوات وان كان
يحاول القاء اللون على روسيا بسبب فشله في
التوصل الى اتفاق المشترك بشان اعلان
مجموعه 20 هذا يعني ان الغرب لم ينجح
موسى وده البيان نددت باشد العبارات بما
اثبته عدوان روسيا الاتحاديه وطالبت
بانسحابها الكامل وغير المشروط من اراضي
اوكرانيا مع التاكيد على اختلاف وجوهات
النظر بشان الوضع والعقوبات ضد روسيا
واعتبرت مسوده بيان القمه ان مجموعه 20
ليست منصه لحل المشكلات الامنيه مع تاكيد
الرئيس الاندلسي جوكو ويدودو انه ان لم
تنتهي الحرب فسيكون من الصعب على العالم
المضيق قدما في القمه انضم رئيس الاوكراني
الى نظيره الامريكي في محاوله لاقناع قاده
المجموعه باتخاد المزيد من الخطوات لعزل
روسيا دبلوماسيا واقتصاديا وحددا 10 شروط
لانهاء الصراع منها انسحاب كامل للقوات
الروسيه واستعاده اوكرانيا كامله سيطره
على ارضها متحدثا بعد ايام على استعاده
بلاده مدينه خيرسون الاستراتيجيه
من القوات الروسيه
[موسيقى]
اريد ان تنتهي هذه الحرب الروسيه
العدوانيه بشكل عادي وعلى اساس ميثاق
الامم المتحده والقانون الدولي لن نسمح
لروسيا ان تنتظر انتهائها وتحشى قواتها ثم
تبدا سلسله جديده من الارهاب وزعزعه
الاستقرار العالمي انا مقتنع الان انه
الوقت الذي يجب ويمكن فيه وقف الحرب
الروسيه المدره
في القمه التقى بيضا برئيس الوزراء
الهنديه الذي يعتبر تعامله مهما في تامين
حد اقصى تسعى الولايات المتحده لفرضه على
سعر النفط الروسيه لتقليل ارباح موسكو
التي تستثمرها في قاعدتها الدفاعيه اما
الحليف الاخر الصين فامتنع مسؤولها عن
انتقاد الحرب الروسيه علنا رغم تجنب بكين
دعم الروس على ايضا فلم تزودهم باسلحه على
سبيل المثال الرئيس الامريكي قال خلال
اجتماعي امس مع نظيره الصيني جيمنج انه ما
ناقش الحرب وقعد التاكيد على اعتقادهما
المشترك بان استخدام او حتى التلويح
باستخدام الاسلحه النوويه غير مقبول على
الاطلاق في اشاره الى تهديدات موسكو
المبطنه باستخدام اسلحه ذريه مع تراجعي
غزوها لاوكرانيا